[Music]
it was revealed last week that president
trump is currently
421 million dollars
in debt and the national security
implications
are oh look a 20
bill hey does this belong to anyone
is this yours is it yours
tarek did you drop this oh it's all
yours bud
whoa twenty dollars
you know what that means right
i've got twenty dollars more
than the president you may
not think it's a lot but it's more than
what trump's got
i've got twenty dollars more
than the president i've got twenty
dollars more than he has
maybe i could lead a nation maybe i
could host a reality show
i could say i'm a genius billionaire
when in reality i blow maybe
america works for the rich and the poor
the poor being donald trump
i could sink billions of dollars in
failing businesses and land right on my
rub
i'm landing on my big fat ramp
i've got 20
more than the president
and it really blows my mind we've both
had our credit cards declined
i've got 20 more than the president
i've got 20 dollars more than he has
hey tarik do you have change for a 20
hmm
let's see i've got
one dollar more than donald trump two
dollars more than he's worth
three dollars more than my dear leader
makes me feel like i'm king of the earth
four dollars he would like to borrow
from me
it really blows my mind six seven eight
hating poor people when you got more
death than almost all poor
people combined on 10 11. it says me to
happen this man is a financial wreck
12 13 14. eating as his restaurant and
he's got to skip out on the check
15 16 17 18. he owes everyone money and
they're still
waiting 19. would be plenty
but look at me ma i've got 20.
i've got 20
more than the president
people thought he was the goat he's just
a grifter trying to stay afloat
i've got dollars more than the president
i've got twenty dollars more a whole
twenty dollars more
i've got twenty dollars
[Applause]
yes
[Music]
you